Wie ich gehört habe, hat sich
die Kaiserin Elisabeth, Sisi genannt,
den Apfelstrudel vom Demel unterirdisch
in die Hofburg servieren lassen.
Es ist ja fast schon eine Hauptspeise.
Mit Suppe und Apfelstrudel, glaube ich,
ist auch der Kalorienbedarf gedeckt.
Es gibt eine Unzahl
an Strudelarten oder Strudelsorten.
Allein bei den süßen gibt es den Apfelstrudel,
den Topfenstrudel, den Kirschstrudel,
den Erdbeerstrudel, den Marillenstrudel.
Mein Name ist Rudolf Swonar,
ich bin Chef-Zuckerbäcker
beim Demel in Wien am Kohlmarkt
und backe seit meinem
sechsten Lebensjahr Apfelstrudel.
Wir starten beim Apfelstrudel
mit dem gezogenen Strudelteig,
bestehend aus Mehl, Salz, einem Ei,
lauwarmem Wasser und Öl.
Jetzt kommen wir eigentlich zur
Hauptattraktion beim Wiener Apfelstrudel:
Wir ziehen jetzt den Strudelteig.
Das ist die Kunst der Zuckerbäcker,
das zu können.
Wenn man den Strudelteig nach oben wirft,
dann zieht er sich nach außen,
wird in der Mitte noch dünner und dünner.
Der Strudel ist jetzt so dünn ausgezogen,
dass man das Buch lesen könnte.
Die Brösel beim Strudel
nehmen dem Apfel das Wasser,
das heißt, die Butterbrösel saugen das auf,
und er wassert nicht aus.
Jetzt machen wir unsere Rumrosinen.
Wichtig ist auch:
Die Rosinen saugen jetzt
eigentlich den Rum auf.
Man ist das so gewohnt,
dass er süß-sauer ist.
Ich bin Josefa Wilhelm,
bin Obstbäuerin in Puch bei Weiz,
dem größten Apfeldorf Österreichs.
Und wir produzieren 16 verschiedene
Äpfelsorten [Apfelsorten].
Das Klima hier eignet sich
ganz gut für ’n Apfelanbau,
weil wir sehr kühle Nächte im Herbst haben
und sehr warme Herbsttage,
und die sind eben dann auch verantwortlich,
dass der Apfel schön rot und gelb wird.
Der Strudelteig ist hauchdünn.
Wären die Äpfel jetzt zu stark,
zu dick, zu grob geschnitten,
würden die Äpfel den Strudelteig zerstören.
Jetzt geben wir den Zimtzucker dazu.
Dann geben wir unsere Butterbrösel drüber.
Das gibt dem Strudel dann
einen wirklich guten Geschmack.
Sollte man zum Beispiel
jetzt einen Apfel haben,
der nicht die entsprechende Säure hat,
dann muss man halt die Menge vom
Zitronensaft a bissi erhöhen.
Dann wird die vordere Seite vom Strudel
nach oben gezogen.
Und der ganze Strudel wird gerollt.
Der Strudel wird dann noch
an der Oberfläche mit Butter eingestrichen.
Passt.
Traditionell wird der Apfelstrudel
als Apfelstrudel serviert,
einfach mit Staubzucker bestreut
und dann genossen.
Einfach schmeckt er am besten.